it's night time right right and it's
raining what year is it i have to know
what year it is
it's whenever you guys died dude 1670.
alabama alabama we're [__] hanging
asians in alabama
okay so let's just pretend let's just
pretend it's alabama okay it's
in the 60s you're in the stocks i think
they're gonna do something tomorrow like
hang me up or something
i don't think hangi is like a surprise
party i think what's your name again
my name is reggie can i call you master
reggie then
i mean you can master reggie um yeah
just don't say it too loud okay
can you sneak me out of here i can
probably come back tomorrow night and
help you tonight i can just give you
water and also have this small bag of
fresh pears oh i love pears thank you i
know you do
um but if they're gonna hate me tomorrow
then what's tomorrow night gonna what is
that gonna do
yeah it's a good point actually gonna be
a little late can you
say something inspirational to me to
make you feel comfortable yeah
comfortably
i'm gonna tell you this that even though
a lot of the books and stuff just show
that god just you know has like a lot of
white people in heaven
that everybody's allowed